quand il était petit j'adorais les
cartes
ces cartes vous savez on les regarde
et puis on retient comme ça des noms un
peu exotique parfois des noms de fleuves
des noms de villes et de deux-montagnes
regarde les frontières on regarde un peu
les formes on est on est un coup sur le
fleuve amour on a un coût sur
tegucigalpa on est un peu partout et en
fait les cartes c'est quelque chose
d'assez passionnant quand on y pense
parce que du coup ça nous met dans une
dans un monde
et parfois quand j'étais petit comme ça
je m'amuse à faire des quizz avec les
copains je m'amusais avec mon pote
vincent et on essayait de voir quelle
était la ville qui correspondait à quel
pays etc
et puis aussi j'adorais dessiner
j'adorais dessiner des cartes et on voit
bien que il ya certes un espace où on
est avec le crayon et on est là avec
tout simplement voilà le trac la main
qui tremble peu comme une présentation
on a cette main qui tremble et c'est
souvent là que c'est intéressant parce
que c'est dans ces espaces frontières et
finalement on se trouve face à des zones
de tension des choses a expliqué et puis
un jour comme ça sur une carte de la
francophonie j'ai mis le doigt sur ce
pays et ce pays
mais je vous propose tout simplement de
vous y amener ce soir parce qu'il m'a
appris beaucoup de choses et si je
devais comme ça vous aider à le deviner
je vous dirais que ça a l'air simple le
nom de famille du premier ministre de ce
pays c'est philippe il a actuellement il
est chef du gouvernement
sauf que c'est peut-être pas celui
auquel vous pensez c'est pavel pavel
philippe parce qu ils pas pareil que
l'autre donc ça n'a rien à voir mais
c'est quand même amusant d'avoir deux
premiers s'ils portent le même nom maman
alors ce pays or pour donner quand même
quelques exemples il faut quelques
indices c'est à la fois un pays tu
représente 1 2 millièmes de la richesse
européenne fois où tout cumul c'est un
pays qui représente 1 500e du territoire
de la russie mais qui a terminé
troisième alors oublions en 2017
il faut quand même si l'intéressé un
petit peu
je vais vous dire aussi ce que ce n'est
pas ce pays ce pays c'est pas la
syldavie peut-être que certains d'entre
vous sont des fans l'ultime de tintin
peut-être que vous aimez vous connaissez
la différence entre les cils damées et
la bordurie mais tout ça non c'est pas
ça mais on s'y rapproche ce pays c'est
pas non plus la pole d'avis alors la
pole d'avis c'est à dire à très peu de
chose a très peu de monde je vous
rassure c est un pays qu'on trouve de
manière imaginaire sur dans la prose de
boris vian
et puis on le trouve aussi dans un
certain nombre de de canular ce soit de
journalistes ou de canulars de
mathématiciens bref ce n'est pas ça
c'est pas non plus la gagaouzie la
gagaouzie n'a elle même rien à voir avec
une certaine chanteuse pop lady gaga n'a
rien avec la gagaouzie je tiens à vous
lire mais cette gagaouzie en fête existe
une petite partie du pays qui nous
intéresse quand on se rapproche quand
même et puis notre pays bas ce n'est pas
non plus la bessarabie mais là aussi on
s'en approche
alors c'est moi que je vous ai
suffisamment fait lambiner comme ça
voilà ce pays dont je veux vous parler
c'est la moldavie alors pourquoi la
moldavie c'est vrai quand on y regarde
de plus près c'est là à peu près la
taille de la belgique superficie c'est
également une population qui est
légèrement supérieur à la bretagne vous
donner un ordre de grandeur 3,5 millions
d'habitants
et c'est un pays qu'on dit parfois
périphériques artificielle ne sait pas
très bien le mettre sur une carte
je vais essayer de vous montrer en fait
on peut même le mettre au centre d'une
carte ça ça va donc voilà c'est juste
pour vous dire ça et puis pour veut dire
que un jour je me suis rendu je me suis
rendu en meule des me suis rendu parce
que j'avais un stage la troisième année
à sciences po à faire une suite bastien
partons sur un pays comme ça un appui
inattendu alors je m'étais dit qu'il
fallait quand même un pays dont je
pourrais un peu m'aspire et c'est à dire
un pays peut-être pas trop connue mais
je me suis dit bon après tout c'est un
pays que j'avais vu sur ma carte de la
francophonie dont parlait tout à l'heure
et dont je m'étais dit tiens on va
essayer d'y aller et quand je suis allé
sur place j'ai compris une chose c'est
la règle de trois mais une règle de
trois la moldave la règle de droit la
moldave ça veut dire m'a dit écoute si
tu restes trois jours dans ce pays
tu vas avoir l'impression de tout
comprendre tu vois il ya les russophones
yellow roumanophone puis on m'a dit et
si tu restes
trois semaines dans ce pays tu auras
l'impression de ne plus rien comprendre
ou là tu vois ce que compliquer ce qu'on
le dit et moi j'y suis resté trois 3
mois 3 mois donc je vais essayer de m'en
tirer mes propres leçons mais
effectivement ça a été période
extrêmement riche et donc du coup
j'étais ravi de voir ce pays à travers
ce petit théâtre en fait j'ai un talent
à tina qui était le siège de l'alliance
française
alors ce pays il a aussi cette
particularité c'est que je me dis que je
vous ai fait voyager et moi je peux vous
prouver qu'on peut voyager sans quitter
son appartement parce que quand on y
pense quelqu'un qui aurait vécu tout le
xxème siècle à chisinau
eh bien il aurait eu quatre pays
différents
oui c'est surprenant pour nous mais
lorient quatre pays différents il aurait
d'abord été menés quatre personnes
auraient été né sous l'empiré russe
l'empiré tsariste celui des romanov
ensuite dans l'entre-deux-guerres
cette personne aurait grandi dans le
royaume de roumanie or une autre époque
autre période et puis ensuite et bien
après la seconde guerre mondiale la même
personne toujours dans le même
appartement
finalement on serait resté là aussi un
temps est bien citoyen soviétique et en
91 pierre au crépuscule de sa vie il
vient cette personne aura été tout
simplement un citoyen molleda donc on
voit que sans changer de pays ont peu
changé quatre fois 100 jours des
appartements peut changer quatre fois de
pays et même si on regarde une famille
juive par exemple dont le sort était lié
à chisinau tout au long du xxème siècle
et bien son nom dans le registre
officiel aurait pu s'écrire en
caractères hébraïques
on va pu s'écrire en caractères latins
en caractères syrie selon les époques et
les contextes sociaux et ça c'est
quelque chose aussi de l'extrêmement
intéressant et puis cette moldavie
rien n'est simple parce qu'à la fois
c'est un assez petit pays si je compare
par rapport à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
mais même dans un petit pays comme ça il
ya une partie séparatistes d'un demi
million d'habitants qui s'appelle la
transnistrie et 7 transnistrie bas
première vue on dit bah tiens c'est
après tout il ya la moldavie d'un côté
il ya la transnistrie et donc ce sont
deux choses très différentes mais il
faut voir parce que derrière cette
espèce d'affrontements effectivement on
compare ce conflit séparatiste
eh bien on se rend compte qu'en fait les
populations majoritaires les populations
des deux côtés sont des populations
roumanophone sont des populations
russophones sont des ukrainiens
et de l'autre côté c'est la même chose
donc on a à peu près les deux mêmes
types de populations des deux côtés et
si on regarde de manière plus précise
encore on peut s'apercevoir que en
transnistrie et en moldavie ou à côté
d'une nièce transnistrie c'est au-delà
d'une est donc le niasse c'est ce fleuve
qui au milieu
eh bien on se rend compte que va au-delà
de ce fleuve on a du commerce qui se
fait par valises
on passa du commerce des valises
ailleurs parfois de la contrebande miro
planète est donc tout simplement il ya
cette dimension assez que les laiteries
sont assez fluide et puis parfois le
football réussi là où les politiques ne
réussissent pas ce que je veux dire par
là c'est simplement c'est que si on
regarde le championnat de moldaves de
football
eh bien vous avez un club le sheriff
tiraspol tiraspol c'est la capitale de
la transmission des biens vous allez
voir que le chef tiraspol en fait à
remporter un certain nombre de conflits
qui je ne sais pas mais en tout cas un
certain nombre de matchs peuvent être
conflictuelle éventuel donc en tout cas
ce qui est frappant c'est ça c'est que
l'on voit bien que même quand il ya des
oppositions parfois ne sont pas aussi
tranchées qu'on pourrait le croire dans
un premier temps et puis j'ai envie de
vous parler de rome
ce que vous voyez derrière vous ça va
problème vous rappeler vos cours
d'histoire quand vous étiez s'occuper de
l'antiquité et à un moment vous avez
tous appris ce qu'était que la louve
capitoline la louve capitolina lobby
capitaine capital menée du capitole
cette louve du capitole c'est celle qui
a élevé romulus et rémus et on sait que
ensuite l'un des deux frères a fondé en
753 avant lui avant jésus-christ
la ville de rome cette ville de rome qui
a inspiré ensuite pendant vingt-huit
siècles depuis vingt-huit siècles à la
fois des hommes politiques des poètes et
j'ai presque envie aussi des
cartographes cette loupe du capitole
c'était un cadeau on a fait deux fois à
la moldavie massés devant le musée
d'histoire d'archéologie de la moldavie
on lui a fait une première fois en 1921
quand la roumanie en fait un texte
l'espace et dans ce cas c'est l'italie
qui a fait ce cadeau pour dire vous
faites partie de l'espace atteint 191
même chose cette fois-ci ce sont les
roumains qui ont offert à la moldavie 7
ci-dessus la même lahlou du capital et
si vous regardez bien sûr la carte
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est que
vous avez vu cette première rom qui a
chuté au cinquième siècle
après jésus-christ quand cette rom a
chuté bien il y avait ce qu'on appelait
l'empiré romain d'orient qui était
constituée autour de constantine à
constantinople c'était son ancien nom
était byzance et puis ensuite c'est
devenu istanbul mais constantinople à
vis de l'emploi pourtant bien c'était la
deuxième rome c'est l'as rome qui était
qui dépendait finalement 2 est bien de
de l'empiré byzantin
quand l'empiré byzantin cellule mais
fonderie que s'est il passé et bien tout
simplement il ya une troisième rome
cette troisième rome c'est moscou
pourquoi moscou
et bien tout simplement parce que moscou
c'était un pays qui était le dernier
pays orthodoxes qui est chrétien donc
qu'ils avaient des velléités dans la
région et donc à l'une des manières
finalement d'investir cet espace
demandent-ils le conquérir c'était de
s'affirmer comme cette troisième rome
et donc si vous regardez bien cette
carte ce qui est amusant c'est que vous
avez vous avez un triangle et la
moldavie c'était mieux de ce triangle et
la moldavie un prix un peu de chaque
c'est ça qui est intéressant projet que
la moldavie un peu après jack
si vous pensez à la première rom ce que
la moldavie après la première rom ces
salons évidemment 70% des thermes
romains sont d'origine latine
c'est à la fois à l'aube du capitole
terme de symbole c'est un certain nombre
de structures mentales
ce que la moldavie a pris la deuxième
rome c'est une religion la religion
orthodoxe même si quand on regarde de
plus près cette religion orthodoxe et
bien tout simplement
elle est divisée en dans des
institutions entre ceux qui sont
favorables à la russie est ce qu'ils
sont capables à la roumanie
on voit que là aussi il ya toujours
cette espèce d'enjeux de l'espace
frontalier est donc derrière ça ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir finalement
que la moldavie est un peu au sens de
quelque chose même si ça vous paraît
totalement exotique
tout simplement parce qu'on attend sa
pensée la moldavie comme une périphérie
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
qu'en réalité elle est un résumé vivant
de cet euro je voulais là-dessus
conclure peut-être avec quelques idées
simples
c'est comme vous le voyez moi je ne suis
pas sûr du rhum fut plutôt sur du cognac
et vous avez certainement reconnu cette
belle kalachnikov qui était filmé
photographié sur place et on peut se
dire après tout ce genre d' espaces
c'est un espace où on a du conflit on a
lieu ce conflit dont on parle
un peu entre des gens qui sont plutôt
favorables à la roumanie des gens qui
sont plutôt favorables à la russie avec
tout un tas de conséquence finalement
sur la vie quotidienne
mais ce que j'avais envie peut-être de
vous montrer sait aussi que ces espaces
ce sont des espaces frontières un espace
frontière c'est un espace qui peut
parler entre plusieurs espaces c'est par
exemple de l'opposition millénaire entre
les français les allemands et bien il ya
ce luxembourg qui permet de parler aux
uns aux autres et de traduire quelque
chose peut-être que la moldavie à
l'avenir aura cette manière à elle de
faire aller ensemble les enjeux
européens et la russie
et puis ce qui est intéressant avec la
moldavie c'est que il faut la penser de
la manière suivante il faut penser à
marc bloch marc bloch et cet historien
français l'école des annales un grand
tenant compte historien du xxème siècle
qui nous disait il ya deux catégories de
personnes qui ne pourront jamais
comprendre l'histoire de france
la première catégorie de personne c'est
ce qu'ils disent qu'ils ne se sentent
pas lier tout simplement qu'ils n'ont
pas d'émotions au sacre de roide france
à reims
et puis nous dit aussi celui qui ne
comprend pas ce qu'est l'émotion de la
fête de la fédération à la révolution
française
celui qui ne comprend pas les soldats de
l'an ii celui là non plus ne comprend
pas l'histoire de france eh bien j'ai
envie de dire que la moldavie
c'est un peu une manière de penser
l'europe en essayant de regarder d'un
côté de l'autre et peut-être que le
meilleur héritage quelques données en
tout cas moi c'est ce que ça va donner
c'est de travailler un esprit critique
parce que quand vous avez besoin d'un
esprit critique
il faut absolument regarder plusieurs
versions à la fois et je vous conseille
de regarder à deux fois ce que la mode
est je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]